How many voters will cast their vote this
November on the basis of a candidate’s position
on abortion?
Survey data collected by several pollsters
provides a rough gauge.
When asked by Gallup how the abortion issue
might affect their vote, around 2 in 10 Americans
answer that a candidate MUST share their views
on the issue.
That’s a significant single-issue bloc.
Nearly half, however, say that abortion will be
one of many important factors, while 3 in
10 say abortion won’t be a factor for them.
The responses have been fairly consistent
in Gallup’s surveys for more than two decades.
Quinnipiac University phrases its question
differently from Gallup’s.
In their latest poll from December 2017, 64
percent of registered voters said that they
could still vote for a candidate if they did
not agree with the candidate on the issue
of abortion, while 29 percent said they could
not.
On abortion questions generally, men and women
do not differ.
For most Americans, then, abortion is not
a litmus test.
Will abortion be a litmus test issue for you in November? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.